a
[Aplausos]
viver em Dois Mundos diferente é uma
coisa tão estranha foi assim que eu
comecei o texto que sem querer mudou o
rumo da minha vida meu nome é Thiago
Torres Eu tenho 20 anos
nasci no ano 2000 na favela do Jardim
Vista Alegre Brasilândia extremo norte
de São Paulo e cresci na favela do
Jardim Elisa Maria também na Brasilândia
e atualmente eu moro na Quebrada em
Guarulhos e foi quando eu resolvi fazer
um desabafo no meu Facebook sobre o
choque de realidade vivida por alguém
que é da periferia de São Paulo e
estudar na maior Universidade do Brasil
que eu fiquei conhecida na internet como
chavoso da USP a USP sempre foi muito
distante da minha realidade e hoje
depois de tá estudando lá há três anos
de ter passado por várias experiências
cabulosa e também adquirir bastante
conhecimento eu consigo entender muito
melhor porque e não é porque que o
ensino superior a educação como um todo
são tão distantes de nós A Verdade mano
é que as periferias de São Paulo são
espaços de segregação da população negra
e Pobre quando eu falo o que elas e o
centro São dois mundos diferentes eu não
estou exagerando muito a gente pegar por
exemplo o índice de desenvolvimento
humano de diferentes regiões de São
Paulo a gente vai ver que em Moema por
exemplo um bairro nobre da região
central é de zero,
961 o IDH maior do que o da Noruega e da
Suíça da Dinamarca já se a gente pegar o
IDH de marsillac por exemplo no extremo
sul é 0,700 e um menor do que vários
países pobres do mundo incluindo o
Suriname a Líbia o Líbano e nada disso
por acaso na realidade só o centro e o
centro expandido de São Paulo que
realmente foram pensados as res o
séricas Principalmente as mais extremas
como a própria Brasilândia ou Guaianazes
ou Grajaú elas foram ocupadas ocupadas
principalmente por migrantes nordestinos
pobres em sua maioria negros e negras
que vieram para São Paulo em busca de
melhores condições de vida e na
realidade foram essas pessoas que
levantar essa cidade que transformaram
ela na maior Metrópole da América Latina
que mantém ela funcionando até hoje mas
que não tem acesso a nada do que elas
próprias construíram produziram né foram
essas pessoas que construir a
Universidade de São Paulo foram elas que
levantaram todos os prédios da Avenida
Paulista o Teatro Municipal a sala São
Paulo
mas essas pessoas não frequenta esses
espaços elas não têm acesso ao que elas
próprias construíram ela só saem das
suas periferias para ir no centro
trabalhar trabalhar e manter esses
espaços em funcionamento mas nunca
usufruir deles elas as periferias
pegam duas horas de transporte público
sucateado caro e chega no centro só para
trabalhar é por isso que eu acho que a
minha entrada na USP foi tão
significativa não só para mim mas para
minha família para minha classe para mim
ancestralidade porque representou uma
quebra nesse ciclo eu filho de
imigrantes nordestinos minha mãe de
Pernambuco meu pai do Piauí comecei aí
no centro de São Paulo não só para
trabalhar mas para estudar para
intelectualizar para adquirir
conhecimento e para estudar do lado dos
filhos da Elite Paulistana do lado dos
filhos dos políticos dos ministros
juízes e eu sem nenhuma vergonha filho
de uma faxineira só que eu não acho que
as minhas conquistas individuais sejam
suficientes É lógico que eu fico muito
feliz de tá estudando na USP mas eu não
consigo me sentir totalmente contemplado
toda vez que eu entro lá dentro e não
encontro tantas pessoas parecidas comigo
estudando lá enquanto não deu e a
maioria do pessoal se parece comigo né e
é muito doido você sair da sua casa
olhar para o seu bairro e ver um cenário
tá ligado E aí você pega duas horas de
busão de metrô e chega em outro lugar
mano e ver uma outra realidade quando eu
saio no meu bairro eu vejo um reflexo do
que é esse sistema eu vejo o bares
lotados de trabalhadores cansados eu
vejo jovens da minha idade com mochila
nas costas fazendo entrega para essas
empresas de aplicativo que exploram eles
eu vejo jovens da minha idade e com a
minha aparência usando o drogas de forma
inconsequente e vendendo também jovens
da minha idade com a minha aparência
inocente ser Acredite pela polícia Eu
sempre gosto muito de citar os Racionais
e na música Fim de Semana no Parque eles
falam trecho que é assim aqui não vejo
nenhum Clube poliesportivo da molecada
frequentar nenhum incentivo
o investimento no lazer é muito escasso
o centro comunitário é um fracasso se
quisesse destruir você está no lugar
certo tem bebida e cocaína sempre por
perto ou seja não têm oportunidades Tem
sim muita gente querendo espaços de
lazer cultura educação
para desenvolver as suas habilidades as
suas capacidades mas elas não encontra
oportunidade para isso e não por acaso a
maioria das pessoas envolvidas nesse
cenário são negras
já quando eu chego no Butantã que é onde
fica o USP o cenário é totalmente
diferente né lá eu vejo prédios luxuosos
carrões casas bonitas EA maioria das
pessoas envolvidas nesse cenário são
brancas essas pessoas que vivem nessa
realidade elas têm todas as
oportunidades nas mãos delas elas já
nasce com o futuro trilhado com a
trajetória de sucesso traçar o e ver
toda essa desigualdade de perto
diariamente é muito doloroso e foi
justamente essa dor que eu tentei
retratar ali naquele texto que viralizou
não só a dor né mas a esperança também
uma grande esperança me move a esperança
de que a gente vai sim conseguir superar
todas essas condições horríveis que Eu
mencionei aqui mas eu entendo que isso
depende da nossa organização e da nossa
luta coletivas O que passa primeiro por
uma compreensão da realidade A gente
precisa entender o funcionamento desse
sistema como ele surgiu como ele se
desenvolveu como ele se mantém e para
onde a gente quer ir né para gente
conseguir realmente mudar essa realidade
e a justamente para que a gente não
consiga responder essas perguntas que a
educação que o conhecimento é negado a
nós dá Justamente por isso que eu alguém
conseguiu e as estatísticas e furar
bolha uso o meu alcance o meu canal na
internet para dialogar diretamente com
os meus instigar neles o gosto pela
leitura pelo estudo pela política e
também ajudar ele tá construir uma
autoestima a gente que é pobre que é
preto não é ensinada se amar a se ver
como alguém valioso cheio de potência né
para fazer um monte de coisa eu acredito
muito que conhecimento é poder e como já
falava o Paulo Freire a educação sozinha
ela não vai mudar o mundo mas ela vai
transformar as pessoas e as pessoas vão
transformar o mundo e nós pretos
periféricos trabalhadores pobres mais do
que ninguém a gente precisa transformar
esse mundo se não eu não sei nem se
ainda vai ter um mundo para gente deixar
para as próximas gerações
e valeu
E aí